zusammen herzlich willkommen an den
empfangsgeräten zu zdf heute live mit
ihren live stream zu aktuellen
ereignissen und diskussionen und die
härteste diskussion der letzten tage ist
ja ob wir einen neuen harten kompletten
lockdown in ganz deutschland brauchen
zwei bundesländer haben diese frage für
sich bereits beantwortet einmal sachsen
dort wird ab kommenden montag alles
dicht gemacht schulen kitas und die
meisten geschäfte müssen schließen
und heute hat auch berlin angekündigt
nach zu ziehen wann genau ist aber noch
offen
berlins regierender oberbürgermeister
müller sagte heute das müssen man mit
brandenburg noch verhandeln die rede ist
da derzeit entweder vom zwanzigster
dezember oder vom 23 dezember für viele
wissenschaftler und auch für das robert
koch institut ist das ein sehr logischer
schritt
präsident wieler hat heute wieder eine
seiner pressekonferenzen gegeben und
dort hat er folgendes gesagt wenn die
menschen nicht von alleine diese 60
prozent reduktion schaffen dann dann
muss man sicher andere maßnahmen sich
überlegen ja wenn es nicht gelingt dann
sehe ich keine andere möglichkeit
ja und er hat gewarnt das
infektionsgeschehen könnte schnell
wieder kippen die fallzahl exponentiell
ansteigen dafür reichen wenige fälle aus
und das müssen wir verhindern gibt es
also keine andere lösung das möchte ich
heute diskutieren mit diesen beiden
herren hinter mir einmal karl lauterbach
gesundheitspolitischer sprecher der spd
bundestagsfraktion und konstantin kühle
in die verstärker der fdp-fraktion und
natürlich auch mit eurem mit ihren im
chat und im livestream bitte gerne
fragen und kommentare reinschreiben in
die dafür vorgesehene spalten oder an
verfolgte - live at zdf.de die
rasseliste als eingeblendet werden wenn
nicht machen als leicht nochmal ist aber
erst mal hallo zu neuen gefechten hallo
schönen guten abend alle wir haben da
irgendwo ein kleines tonprobleme im
hintergrund ich hoffe das wird gleich
gelöst und ich muss schon gleich sagen
auch den beiden gesprächspartnern wir
können sie nicht wirklich gleichzeitig
sprechen lassen das lässt unsere unser
studio hier noch nicht zu
das heißt so ein bisschen wie beim duell
beim zweiten duell beiden gegen jump
müssen sie sich abwechseln das ist ja
vielleicht der diskussionskultur ja
vielleicht ist ganz zuträglich ich werde
ihn jeweils dann das wort erteilen oder
sie können ja dann auch mit einem
handzeichen geben wenn sie da jetzt ganz
dringend eingreifen wollen ich fange
jetzt mal bei herrn cooler an die fdp
war in den letzten wochen und monaten
wird auch relativ skeptisch was die
korona politik der bundesregierung
angeht wenn sie jetzt herrn wieder da
hören der sagt wenn das so weiter geht
dann geht hier nichts mehr ändern sie
dann vielleicht ihre meinung mal also
natürlich sind wir dankbar für den input
der fachleute und der wissenschaft diese
menschen wissen genau wie sich die
zahlen derzeit entwickeln und es ist
auch klar dass angesichts der
infektionszahlen und der todesfälle die
wir jeden tag zu beklagen haben die
situation nicht so bleiben kann wie sie
jetzt ist was uns als fdp ärgert ist
dass wir immer noch keine
langzeitstrategie haben und das
offensichtlich anfang november
versprechungen gemacht worden sind die
man nicht einhalten kann es ist gesagt
worden wenn wir nur für einige wochen
die gastronomie die kulturbetriebe
die sportstätten schließen dann haben
wir um weihnachten herum eine situation
bei der wir gut über die festtage kommen
und all das hat sich nicht gelohnt und
jetzt laufen die ministerpräsidenten
durch die gegend und sprechen über einen
harten lockdown für 2 für drei wochen
und da fragt man sich was soll
eigentlich mitte januar bei ähnlichen
temperaturen wie jetzt anders sein
es ist keine ideologische frage ob man
jetzt in der woche vor weihnachten zwei
drei vier tage früher mit härteren
maßnahmen beginnen darüber muss man
angesichts dieser zahlen dieser
dramatischen zahlen diskutieren aber die
ratio dahinter die frage
wissenschaftliche einbindung in
verbindung mit einer langzeitstrategie
die sehen wir nicht und deswegen sind
wir bei aller notwendigkeit für
strengere maßnahmen skeptisch ob man
sich das wirklich gut überlegt hat aber
dann müssten sie ja eigentlich mit der
bundeskanzlerin auf meiner linie seien
die war sehr unzufrieden nach diesen
letzten bund-länder-treffen und drei
ministerpräsidenten regieren auch hält
fdp unterstützung die haben das
mittlerweile oder mit zusammen
verhindert dass ein härterer lockdown
kommt bitte um entschuldigung ich habe
leider nur die hälfte verstanden also
ich bin anderer auffassung als die
bundeskanzlerin weil sie an der spitze
einer bundesregierung steht die
offensichtlich versprechungen gemacht
hat die jetzt nicht eingehalten werden
es kann doch nicht sein dass im november
menschen versprochen wird dass es eine
soforthilfe gibt für betriebsschließung
und dann geht der november ins land der
dezember ins land geht der januar ins
land und dann wird jetzt über eine noch
strengere schließung von betrieben
nachgedacht so kann man eine
langzeitstrategie für die wirtschaft
nicht fahren noch anfang dezember hat
sich der bundeswirtschaftsminister
mit einkaufstüten ablichten lassen und
hat gesagt einkaufen sei eine
patriotische pflicht und wenige tage
später soll jetzt der einzelhandel dicht
gemacht werden obwohl im september
jens spahn noch gesagt hat mit dem
wissen von heute würde man nach der
ersten welle schon den einzelhandel
nicht wieder schließen also die
langzeitstrategie die fehlt auch die
verbindung aus dem einzelhandel aus den
fragen der gastronomie aus vagen sport
kultur und freizeit und infekt
sonst seien die fehlen aber eins ist
auch klar die situation kann nicht so
bleiben wie sie jetzt ist es muss
maßnahmen geben diese maßnahmen müssen
aber unterlegt seien mit blick auf die
wirtschaft mit hilfen die auch
tatsächlich bei den betroffenen ankomme
sonst haben wir mitte januar massive
insolvenzen und haben dann ein problem
das noch viel größer ist als jetzt gut
dann gucken wir mal was herr lauterbach
dazu sagt der ton zu ihnen funktioniert
nicht hören bei uns an
liegt es vielleicht daran dass hier noch
irgendwo lautsprecher angeschlossen
haben
ich habe keine lautsprecher
angeschlossen
gut jetzt funktioniert gut wir versuchen
das einfach mal herr lauterbach sehen
sie dieses problem auch dass es keine
langzeitstrategie gibt dass die fehlt
nein und ich widerspreche auch im
übrigen herrn kohle der eben gesagt hat
dass das ganze sich nicht gelohnt hat
das ist falsch also wenn wir den cut
nicht gemacht hätten dann hätten wir
heute 40.000 neuinfektionen werden
wahrscheinlich um die 1000 todesopfer
hatte beklagen müssen somit also obwohl
wir jetzt nicht durch sind haben wir
immerhin so viel gemacht dass das
exponentielle wachstum gebrochen werden
konnte und wir immerhin also in eine
situation gekommen sind die stabil ist
dass das nicht reicht es ganz klar aber
wir haben zumindest sehr viel mehr
gemacht als die fdp vorgeschlagen hatte
das was wir gemacht haben hat
offensichtlich nicht gereicht aber dann
hätte das wenige was die fdp
vorgeschlagen hätte erst recht nicht
gehalten und man muss auch was
wissenschaftler sagen wir können also
tatsächlich hier kann eine
langfristperspektive business oder bis
april anbieten das ist einfach unseriös
das geht nicht weil die dynamik dieser
infektion ist dramatisch das muss man
einfach sagen die zweite welle wird also
an der pandemie immer sehr viel stärker
als die erste fahne weg wir haben also
bisher nur das exponentielle wachstum
unter in den griff bekommen wir müssen
jetzt dringend einen härteren schatten
also beschließen und mit frage auch ganz
ehrlich das ist unklar ob wir damit bis
zum 10
januar erfolg haben werden aber werden
auf jeden fall jetzt in einem scharfen
schatz darüber gehen müssen und zwar so
schnell wie möglich weil sonst haben wir
bis ende januar
25.000 zusätzliche todesopfer
die fragen die sich viele stellen ist
aber tatsächlich wie schlimm ist die
situation sie haben das gerade wieder
eine ziemlich hohe mögliche todesopfer
zahl genannt sie haben gestern interview
gesagt wir hätten die kontrolle über die
pandemie verloren rki-chef wieder geht
ja nicht so weit der sagt das was sie
gerade auch gesagt haben wir haben ein
plateau erreicht das ist nicht genug
aber das ist auch fragil aber er macht
nicht so einen ich sag mal einen
alarmzustand sondern sagt wir müssen
jetzt schauen ist es nicht auch
vielleicht ein bisschen alarmistisch von
ihrer seite dass sie mit solchen großen
zahlen operieren
nein ich operiere ja nicht mit großen
zahl ich gehe jetzt vor neben szenario
aus dass in über die weihnachtstage die
fallzahlen nicht ansteigen werde das ist
ja ausgesprochen optimistisch aber sagen
wir die fallzahlen würde nicht anstalten
dann würden also bis ende januar 400 bis
500 menschen pro tag stärken und das
sind rechnerisch anschließender garten
bis dahin 25.000 tote
das heißt das ist das szenario was
optimistischer weise davon ausgeht dass
also um also die weihnachtszeit die zahl
der infizierten nicht deutlich anstatt
wie das zum beispiel bei thanks giving
in den usa und in kanada der fall
gewesen
das heißt die rechnen ist mario sondern
ist es nämlich schon einmal das heißt
die rechnet nicht damit dass die
menschen sich jetzt weiter
zusammenreißen um irgendwie solche
fallzahlen zu verhindern
die leute die an weihnachten sterben die
sind ja alle schon infiziert also
tatsächlich wir wissen doch wie viele
sich jetzt in den letzten tagen
infiziert haben das sind doch diejenigen
die in drei wochen sterben werden das
habe ich die nächsten drei wochen kann
ich schon modellieren ohne dass sich
kompliziert modellieren
und es würde die fahrzeit nur untergehen
wenn tatsächlich die leute weniger
kontakte an weihnachten hätten als sie
heute abend aber die tod die
sterbezahlen in drei wochen die können
wir doch jetzt schon ausrechnen weil wir
die zahl der neuinfizierten in diesem
tag und deren altersverteilung somit wir
wissen ungefähr wie viele anleihen an
neujahr sterben werden
wie viele danach sterben werden im
januar hängt davon ab wie viele sich
anja nimm an weihnachten infizieren und
da bin ich da optimist zumindest und
sage das ist es wirklich nur mehr werden
aber das steht noch auf was selbst
voraus dass wir das zu beschlüssen
kommen dass über die feiertage nicht
locker
aber wir müssen ja noch doch feststellen
die bundesländer reagieren jetzt jedes
für sich berlin und sachsen wollen jetzt
schon vor weihnachten dichtmachen in
bayern gelten ausstrahlen strengere
regeln als anderswo der katastrophenfall
ausgerufen worden
heiko kunst man hat uns nur ein
überblick darüber verschaffen was jetzt
eigentlich wo gilt angesichts nicht
sinkender corona infektionen wollen
etliche bundesländer den shutter und
verschärfen
ein einheitliches vorgehen gibt es
bislang nicht doch vielerorts werden
ähnliche maßnahmen ergriffen so hat
berlins regierender bürgermeister müller
angekündigt dass alle läden außerdem
lebensmittelhandel schließen müssen am
band stehen noch nicht fest
die ferien sollten entweder verlängert
werden oder der unterricht sollte
digital erfolgen in bayern gelten
bereits seit gestern härterer
beschränkungen das haus darf nur noch
aus triftigen gründen verlassen werden
in sogenannten hot spots sind zudem von
21 bis 5 uhr
ausgangssperren vorgesehen auch an den
schulen gelten schärfere regeln komplett
alle schulen und kitas dicht so heißt es
ab montag in sachsen das bundesland mit
der höchsten instanz schließt zudem
einen großteil der geschäfte
zudem herrscht in der öffentlichkeit
masken pflicht genauso wie in berlin und
bayern sollen diese regeln bis
mindestens zum 10
januar gelten so also es wird was getan
auf bundes länder ebene aber jedes
bundesland eben für sich hier gibt es
schon fragen und eine muntere diskussion
wie immer die aufforderung an dieser
stelle bitte sachlich zu diskutieren ich
weiß das feld
von euch schwer aber ich glaube ihr
schafft das da gibt es eine frage von
jan lukas schmidt an herrn coole welche
langzeitstrategie hat denn der fdp
also ich glaube es ist ganz wichtig dass
wir nicht bei jeder welle die jetzt
entsteht und da hat herr lauterbach
recht diese erkrankung ist eine
dynamische erkrankung die immer wieder
von neuem auch ausbricht dass man nicht
bei jeder welle wieder am anfang steht
und deswegen muss man die zeit zwischen
bestimmten fällen nutzen um langfristige
strategien auf den weg zu bringen
dazu gehört erstens dass man die
risikogruppen besonders schützt das man
bei der verteilung von fft zwei masken
an risikogruppen schneller wird was man
bei der installation von luftfiltern in
alten- und betreuungs heimen schneller
wird dazu gehört dass man sich über
einkaufszeiten für besonders gefährdete
gruppen gedanken macht dazu gehört dass
man eine test strategie fährt für das
personal was in diesen einrichtungen
tätig ist und dazu gehört zweitens dass
wir die chancen der digitalisierung
nutzen wir haben immer noch keine
vernünftige schnittstelle zwischen der
korona app und den gesundheitsämtern wir
haben immer noch keine kompatibilität
auf europäischer ebene was die korona
app angeht wir haben immer noch
schwierigkeiten bei der meldung der
gesundheitsämter nach den zahlen am
wochenende und wir haben nach wie vor im
bereich der bildung und im bereich der
geschäfte des einzelhandels
versprechungen die nicht eingelöst
werden sei es die frage der november der
soforthilfen oder sei es die
betreuungsgarantie die bildungsgarantie
gegeben worden ist das muss erledigt
werden darauf müssen sich eltern darauf
müssen sich die betreiber von geschäften
verlassen können und dann kann man in
den zeiten in denen die infektions
dynamik leicht abnimmt das virus siegt
ist noch lange nicht kann man sich auf
die nächste welle vorbereiten und das
muss man tun damit man nicht das neue
problem jedes mal wieder hat aber die
wird ja da wahrscheinlich doch relativ
lange andauern zumindest jetzt über die
wintermonate herr lauterbach aber man
muss ja doch das stellen die meisten
menschen die mit oder alkohol versterben
sind ältere mitbürger über 60 über 70
das ist die wirkliche große risikogruppe
wäre es da nicht nur die idee diese
menschen besonders zu verhandeln indem
man ihnen zum beispiel neben mehr schutz
maß an wird
die altenheime noch besser schützt indem
man ihn die von der fdp gerade
vorgeschlagen zum beispiel besteht dass
trotz oder reserviert in den
supermärkten wo sie einkaufen gehen
können
ja in der tat so dass wir sehr viel mehr
müssen machen müssen für die aber selbst
bei denjenigen die 65 bis 80 sind dass
du nicht in den pflegeeinrichtungen
leben ist die sterblichkeit sehr hoch
also ungefähr ein prozent und somit was
so werden dort sich meinetwegen zehn
millionen menschen infiziert oder das
wurde einfach durchlaufen dann wären das
also riesige also das ist doch wohl
vertretbar dass mir niemand
ich weiß auch darauf hin dass viele in
der mittleren lebensphase die erkranken
langfristig also an dem syndrom leiden
auch sehr viele frauen den übrigen also
sind längst nicht nur die also eltern
die betroffen sind die eltern haben noch
schwere verläufe die zum tod führen aber
wir wissen mittlerweile dass ein
erheblicher teil derjenigen zwischen 30
und 50 c infiziert werden insbesondere
frauen dass die sehr lange damit kämpfen
müssen und möglicherweise auch so einem
fall nicht mehr komplett genesen dieses
lankowitz syndrom ist auch von größter
bedeutung
das müssen wir auch also bedenken somit
ist nicht nur darum die krankheit zu
verhindern bei denjenigen die in
pflegeeinrichtungen leben obwohl dort
die meisten sterben aber sind auch ist
eine sehr sehr schwere krankheit die
niemand will
auch bei den 30 bis 50 jährigen aber
bringt es denn da was tatsächlich ist
das ganze land wieder runter zu fahren
es ist halt doch wieder nur relativ
kurzfristige strategie das ist ja doch
die kritik der fdp wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe das bringt sehr viel und zwar
wir zählen wir auch die ziel incident
unter 50 200.000 pro woche werden uns
die ständigen fernstudien neue ausdrücke
wie das so nachvollziehen dass wir dann
die kontrolle über die pandemie haben
aber herr leugnen dass sie sagen euch
erstmal unverzichtbar hunderttausend
aber ist klar wenn ich antrete was wir
an instanzen haben wenn ich mir angucke
was fährt instanzen haben ist das nicht
völlig völlig utopisch dass wir auf
diese 50er institut zurückkommen das
haben auch andere länder geschafft
irland hat es geschafft israel hat es
geschafft
korea hat es geschafft das haben schon
viele länder geschafft wieso sollte das
nicht schaffen können
während mir in der tat einen harten
lockt ein paar wochen durchhalten dann
kommen wir auch diese instanz runter
wenn wir das nicht machen dann können
wir das muss man realistischerweise sehr
bis ende märz anfang april kommen wir
aus schaffen also situation nicht mehr
heraus weil das ist einfach so man kann
fast nicht durchlaufen lassen wir können
nicht sagen wir pegeln uns jetzt allen
bei einer inzidenz von 150 oder so das
sind einfach zu viele todesfälle
dann hätten wir dauerhaft promoter 400
oder 500 todesfälle und wir hatten jeden
tag 45 1000 orte die chronisch krank
werden das kann niemals vertreten
da er wird schneller antwort wir müssen
auf 50 wollen herr coole wenn sie sich
jetzt anschauen was die bundesländer
dafür sich selber alles beschließen ist
das nicht im endeffekt auch eine
langzeitstrategie dass jedes bundesland
tatsächlich guckt was ist hier gerade
bei mir an instanzen was es an vorfällen
wie viele krankenhäuser habe ich noch
wie viel der intensivbetten habe ich
noch oben dann tatsächlich gezielt dazu
agieren ja eine regional abgestimmte
strategie ein vorgehen je nach ausbruch
vor ort ist genau der richtige weg man
kann sich je nach incidents zahl dann
das vorgehen überlegen und je stärker
das corona virus an einem bestimmten ort
in deutschland ausbricht umso strenger
müssen die maßnahmen auch sein aber was
ich da im vorteil weil sie förderalismus
die wir in dieser corinna zeit auch
nutzen müssen ja erst wenn sich auf
krediten klagen und gemacht und doch
genau das gerade sie bitte wo ist denn
dann ihre politik wir machen doch genau
das gerade also voll krass was möchten
sie anders machen war verstehe ich als
karriereknick die rahmenbedingung für
die entscheidung der länder sind nicht
gegeben wir haben bei der frage der
digitalisierung in der bildung eine
situation wo die mittel aus dem digital
packt schule nicht abfließen nicht
abgerufen worden sind nicht eingesetzt
werden können für die digitale bildung
an schulen und für die ausbildung der
lehrkräfte das bedeutet dass die
entscheidung in den ländern pro digitale
bildung effektiv nicht getroffen werden
kann weil das geld aus dem digital packt
schule nicht ankommt wir haben ein
versprechen der bundesebene dass es eine
unterstützung für betriebe gibt die
unter locked down maßnahmen im
wenn man im dezember leiden schauen sie
die fdp erkennt absolut an dass es eine
wissenschaftliche notwendigkeit für
strengere maßnahmen in dieser situation
gibt aber es geht einfach nicht dass wir
die kollateralschäden für bestimmte
berufsgruppen für bestimmte gruppen in
diesem land völlig unter den tisch
fallenlassen anfang des jahres ist ihm
vor allem das alles verstimmte zahlung
geleistet werden müssen von
selbstständigen werden die
versicherungen fällig wenn diese leute
in der zeitung lesen im internet lesen
dass die sogenannte soforthilfe erst
ende januar erst im februar ausgezahlt
werden kann
dann stimmen die rahmenbedingungen für
ein regionales vorgehen der bundesländer
nicht und das kann man lieber herr
lauterbach nicht einfach unter den tisch
fallen lassen
ich weiß das zu schätzen dass sich die
gesundheitspolitische und die
wissenschaftliche perspektive hier
einbringen deshalb haben einfach nicht
sein dass uns das in der kader ist was
mit bestimmten gruppen in diesem land
passiert es geht ihm vor allem herr
coole finde ich sie richtig verstehe um
die finanzhilfen es geht ihnen gar nicht
um die frage wann man wo was zu machen
sondern eher um die frage wenn man was
zu machen wie viel geld kriegen wenn die
geschädigten
es geht einmal darum dass diejenigen
denen man versprochen hat dass sie eine
entschädigung bekommen dieses geld auch
tatsächlich schnell sehen damit wir im
januar im februar überhaupt noch
betriebe haben die man retten kann
und es geht darum dass wir nicht vor
jeder welle wieder erneut dieselbe
diskussion führen sondern dass man auch
über ausnahmen dazu kommen kann dass es
eine bestimmte langzeitstrategie gibt
und ich glaube schon dass viele menschen
in der gastronomie im bereich sport
freizeit und kultur sich die frage
stellen war es das im november und im
dezember wirklich wert lieber herr
lauterbach sie werden sagen und sie
werden genau die zahlen beschreiben
können
aus ihrer sicht wie sie sich dargestellt
hätten wenn man das nicht gemacht hätte
aber das tut vielen menschen in diesen
bereichen einfach weh dass jetzt
strengere massnahmen erlassen werden
müssen und das offensichtlich das was
gemacht worden ist entweder nicht
gereicht hat oder in bestimmten
bereichen sogar untauglich weil
vergessen dass die rahmenbedingungen für
die schärferen maßnahmen die wir jetzt
sehen einfach nicht stimmig und wir
werden erleben dass große
kollateralschaden entstehen nicht nur
für wirtschaftliche existenzen sondern
auch für die chancengerechtigkeit in
unserem bildungssystem und für die
geistige gesundheit von vielen menschen
so jetzt dafür lauterbach natürlich
darauf antworten vergessen sie quasi die
kollateralschäden
natürlich nicht also auch versuchen
selbst ab dafür plädiert gemacht gab es
damals schon cool wir haben jetzt wohl
tatsächlich lauterbach wir hatten
probleme wir verstehen sie nicht mehr
gut ist es richtig dass herr lauterbach
worden sich nicht wenn sie uns verstehen
wir haben gerade schon probleme leider
mit ihrer mit ihrer verbindung da ist
sehr viel abgehakt ich frag mal kurz
macht es sinn die noch mal neu
aufzubauen die verbindung einfach zu
ihnen
also es war klar jan in einer ton
verbindungsprobleme und nach einem netz
problem also es kann so gut sagt also
ich höre sehr gut
jetzt scheint es ihr das so
funktionieren wir probieren das noch mal
okay es ist so besser
wundervoll nicht glaube instream kennen
alle diese probleme die wir jeden tag
haben mit diversen videokonferenzen das
bitte ich zu entschuldigen aber ich
glaube ihr und sie wissen wie das ist
also ich versuche es noch mal härter mag
sie haben gerade gesagt sie vergessen
die kollateralschäden nicht
ja ich vergesse die kollateralschäden
auf gar keinen fall
und die müssen noch nicht bedacht werden
sowohl bei den schüler wie auch also in
den unternehmen die unternehmen müssen
sofort wie also hilfe bekommen und wir
müssen den schulausfall den wir jetzt in
kauf nehmen müssen wir müssen wir
nachholen
wir könnten zum beispiel die
sommerferien zwei wochen später beginnen
lassen
aber ich warne davor dass man sagt wir
machen den shutout den wir jetzt
brauchen nur dann wenn die wirtschaft
damit zieht das ist jetzt eine
humanitäre
die wir treffen müssen wir haben die
eine situation wo wir mit jedem tag den
wir ca zusätzliche opfer in kauf nehmen
müssen wir dürfen nicht den fehler
machen dass wir aus parteipolitischen
gründen das zu reden was erreicht wurde
aber die wirtschaft das ist vor allem
das auf der sogenannten auch angekommen
sind selber raus aber die wirtschaft hat
ja das problem dass das geld nicht
ankommt weil es da einfach bearbeitungs
verzögerungen gibt und tatsächlich die
infrastruktur dahinter nicht so schnell
zu funktionieren scheint wie das
versprochen wurde
es arbeitet aber das finanzministerium
minister hatte das
wirtschaftsministerium mit hochdruck
daran
und man dürfe doch dann musste ich immer
als in anderen regionen oder dann kommt
das geld schnell genug an dass das geld
mit abschlagszahlungen so schnell wie
möglich ausgezahlt werden muss sagen
wird mit hochdruck gearbeitet und darauf
haben die menschen auch ein anrecht
trotzdem brach das nicht dazu führen
dass wir dich die maßnahmen selbst in
frage stellen
diese maßnahmen haben jetzt schon in den
letzten wochen hunderte menschen das
leben gerettet
aber wenn wir mal auf die inzidenz und
gucken ich habe mal geschaut also wir
haben in schleswig holstein in
niedersachsen in mecklenburg vorpommern
sieben tage instanzen die sind alle
unter 100 fällen pro 100.000 einwohner
das ist jetzt nicht so schlecht wie
wollen sie denn dann am einzelhändler
erklären dass er jetzt dicht machen muss
davor damit rechnen muss dass das geld
was er dringend braucht oder sie sind
zwei bis vier monaten ankommt weil dafür
hochdruck dahinter ist aber es hat nicht
reicht das ist doch ziemlich schwer
vermittelbar
es ist gut vermittelbar ist gut
vermittelbar das sind schließlich hall
stand und in mecklenburg vorpommern
jetzt auch etwas passieren muss weil 100
ist an incidents dies schon viel zu hoch
und sie steigt über darüber in ort in
diesen bundesländern auch das heißt wir
müssen auch in diesen bundesländern
kämpfen dass wir unter die 50 kommen und
werden wir das erreicht haben
dann kann man über lockerungen
entsprechen aber vorher nicht und
selbstverständlich haben die betroffenen
betriebe ein recht auf die zahlungen
selbstverständlich haben die kinder ein
recht auf die schule
aber wir können jetzt nicht sagen 100
ist nicht so schlecht im vergleich zu
anderen ländern
die zielmarken muss unter 50 sein so wir
machen das malen kurzen break weil wir
sind
hier vor allem auch eine sendung die auf
die zuschauer guckt das ist muss ich
jetzt mal sagen aus moderatorin sich
manchmal ein bisschen schwierig wenn man
zwei gesprächspartner hat deswegen
möchte ich hier eine kurze pause machen
und ein mal gucken was es hier an
kommentaren gibt von euch und ihnen also
einmal gibt es von psd andré auf youtube
die frage warum keinen kompletten locker
und für drei wochen in der zeit in der
sowieso viele betriebe betriebsferien
haben das wird jetzt diskutiert
evd schreibt ich denke dass wir noch vor
weihnachten einen cut brauchen und
überhaupt finde ich es falsch
weihnachten mit zehn personen zu feiern
das risiko ist doch viel zu hoch und ein
anderer user fragt wieso wurde so lange
auf einen harten lockdown verzichtet
warum nimmt sich man aber auch nimmt man
sich nicht in dieser pandemie mal ein
beispiel an china diese frage würde ich
mal an meine beiden gesprächsteilnehmer
weitergeben ist china das gute beispiel
also ich kenne dich chinesische antwort
sehr gut ich habe heute morgen ist an
einer konferenzschaltung mit peking
teilgenommen
das ist eben ein ganz anderes system die
chinesen haben in der ersten welle
extrem hart reagiert und haben dann
beispielsweise ein quarantäne system
aufgebaut für jeden der in einem cluster
gewesen ist wo man also außerhalb des
hauses isoliert wurde
und quasi die einrichtung nicht
verlassen durfte eine so drastische
reaktion ist in keinem demokratischen
lernt also so einfach umsetzbar würde
ich anders sagen
trotzdem ist es richtig dass man von den
chinesen viel lernen kann eingeht wenn
man erst einmal die fallzahlen stark
reduziert hat dann lässt sich die
pandemie leichter kontrollieren da
hatten wir im sommer eine chance wir
haben aber im sommer viel zeit verloren
und haben das wieder zugelassen das sehr
langsam die fallzahlen wichtiger sind
und sind dann mit dem cutter und zu spät
eingestiegen das muss man als
manöverkritik zu lassen das haben die
also das hätten die chinesen deutschland
konsequent war er cool oder chinesische
weg ist wahrscheinlich der erde eher
liberale aber es ist eine
langzeitstrategie wäre die was für sie
nein ich glaube dass wir uns am
demokratischen staaten orientieren
sollten und nicht an autoritären regimen
karl lauterbach hat gerade gesagt man
solle die maßnahmen
nicht ständig in frage stellen das
gegenteil ist richtig in einer
demokratie gehört das ständige
infragestellen der maßnahmen dazu wenn
man die bevölkerung wirklich überzeugen
will ich erinnere daran dass im märz im
april der bevölkerung gesagt worden ist
masken würden nichts bringen
wir sind mittlerweile alle davon
überzeugt weil wir die
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse kennen
das masken bei der verhinderung von
infektions wegen sehr nützlich sind und
deswegen möglichst überall getragen
werden sollten wo es eine
infektionsrisiko gibt also das
hinterfragen von maßnahmen ist ganz
wichtig und die bevölkerung muss
überzeugt werden einer der kommentatoren
hat ja auch darauf hingewiesen dass es
zwischen weihnachten und neujahr eine
zeit gibt wo ohnehin viele betriebe
betriebsferien haben wo viele menschen
auch zu hause sind nicht alle berufe
können sich das erlauben aber bei vielen
ist es eben so und ich glaube es ist
ganz wichtig die wirtschaft hier auch
aufzufordern
soweit es geht auf home office auf
solche lösungen auf betriebsferien zu
setzen das geht bei weitem nicht überall
aber zu sagen wir machen das jetzt
einfach mal ohne einen dialog mit den
betrieben und der wirtschaft das ist der
falsche weg die leute müssen an einem
strang ziehen und das geht nur durch
hinterfragen durch kritik durch ein
großes gespräch in diesem land über die
wirksamkeit von bestimmten maßnahmen und
dazu gehört auch dass man bestimmte
hinterfragt so hier hinterfragen einige
bei uns im chat die maßnahmen oder zum
beispiel auch die empfehlungen von frau
merkel die er in einem interview gesagt
hat wenn man im klassenzimmer kalt ist
sollte man mal klatschen oder vielleicht
ein bisschen hüpfen der schreibt fabian
hartmann auf youtube vielleicht kann mir
das mal kurz zeigen bei mir auf dem
rechner klatschen sie doch selber in die
hand und machen kniebeugen mann mit
maske bei offenem fenster im winter
sitzt da gibt es also viel kritik auch
hier von swan tom stille warum tor
lockdown erst jetzt und nicht schon
mitte november als zum ersten mal klar
war dass die zahlen nicht fallen
und es gibt tatsächlich einige
kommentatoren hier die für die
schulschließungen sind zudem kommen wir
gleich noch aber jetzt möchte ich noch
mal kurz über die situation an den
kliniken sprechen
letzten endes geht es darum dass die
intensivstation nicht überlastet werden
einige sind schon am limit wir haben ja
gestern mit dem chef der deutschen
interdisziplinären vereinigung für inter
tief und notfallmedizin gesprochen dass
des professor uwe janssens und der hat
uns folgendermaßen dazu etwas gesagt
die patienten kommen ja nicht hin die
liegen ja wenn sie einmal auf die
intensivstation kommen 10 14 beatmet
sogar 24 30 tage
das heißt die liegen dann da belegen
einbetten das belegen sie dauerhaft und
sollen sie jeden tag einen patienten
dieser art eine patientin die so lange
auf der intensivstation dazu agieren
dann ist das system irgendwann mal zu
das muss jedem vollkommen klar sein ich
kann ihnen sagen wir haben ungünstige
prognose modelle die wir im augenblick
noch zusammenfassung geht es morgen
übermorgen noch mal veröffentlich werden
wenn wir so weitermachen wie bisher
werden wir halt nicht in einem statement
sondern wir werden eine überbelastung
situation reinkommen das dann aber
spätestens mitte januar als ergebnis
einer lockerungen um das weihnachtsfest
darum hercules sie haben ja gerade auch
schon gesagt sie möchten besonders
gefährdete bevölkerungsgruppen spricht
die alten menschen in altenheimen
besonders schützen jetzt müssen wir aber
feststellen hat das lka heute auch schon
gesagt die vorstelle oder die ausbrüchen
altenheim haben sich verdoppelt trotz
der vorsichtsmaßnahmen heißt das im
endeffekt dann doch dass sie dazu dafür
plädieren müssen altenheime komplett
dicht zu machen und keine besucher mehr
zuzulassen
das wäre eine wirklich sehr scharfe
maßnahme die vermutlich einen beitrag
leisten würde zu einer verringerung der
infektions dynamik in bestimmten
einrichtungen
es gibt aber alternativen beispielsweise
die flächendeckende einführung von fft
zwei masten einmal für die menschen die
dort leben aber auch für die
besucherinnen und besucher natürlich
muss der besucher verkehr auch reduziert
werden und ich frage mich auch wie
realistisch und wünschenswert das ist
gerade um die tage die wir jetzt vor uns
haben darauf zu setzen dass menschen in
diesen einrichtungen gar keine sozialen
kontakte haben ich glaube hier muss ein
mindestmaß an anbindung auch an ein
soziales leben erfolgen aber richtig ist
das will ich auch ganz
unmissverständlich sagen die zahlen
müssen runter die situation auf den
intensivstationen ist dramatisch es
braucht auch strenge maßnahmen es gibt
aber große zweifel ob wir wirklich so
eine strategie jedes mal anwenden können
wenn eine welle
uns gegenüber steht oder ob wir nicht
eine langzeitstrategie brauchen die
rahmenbedingungen für ein regionales
vorgehen sind weiterhin nicht da und
deswegen ist deutschland momentan auf
einen harten shutdown nicht vorbereitet
herr lauterbach wie können sie das denn
erklären das ist jetzt so viele
ausbrüche in den altenheimen gibt das
einfach die und das wird dann über 80
irgendwie wir müssen diese leute besser
schützen es strategien
es sei gut dass der jetzt haben sollte
dann auch die ton aufsätze auf ihrer
seite und darüber hinaus auch machst
dann sagen es ist weil wir haben mehr
menschen die herr lauterbach können sie
nochmal gerade das versuchen was sie
gerade gemacht haben weil der ton ist
wieder zusammengebrochen leider wir
haben kurz das video ist machtlos
wir können mal einmal auf unserer
politbarometer gucken weil das ist
tatsächlich ganz interessant während
einfach versucht den ton zu fixen
wenn wir mal auf oder sind meinen
rechner erhalten denn dort können wir
sehen das ist von heute das
politbarometer wie immer repräsentativ
ungefragt so tatsächlich nichts was man
nicht hochrechnen könnte und wir haben
gefragt aktuell geltende corona
maßnahmen im vergleich zu ende november
sind übertrieben haben 13 prozent der
befragten gesagt das sind viel weniger
als vorher 35 prozent der befragten
sagten sind gerade richtig und 49
prozent sagten müssten härter ausfallen
und wenn wir mal eine reise weitergehen
die bewertung der maßnahmen verlängerung
der maßnahmen bis ende des 10 januar da
haben 82 prozent gesagt das ist richtig
lockerungen an weihnachten da gibt es
quasi eine 50 50 meinung lockerung an
silvester halten 80 prozent der betten
für falsch und man noch eine slide
weiter können wir tatsächlich sehen 73
prozent der befragten sind für einen
harten shutdown
da frage ich doch mal ein cooles sie
scheinen da doch dann mit ihrer idee er
damit
dazu gehören will die fdp nicht amazon
mehrheit gehören
es ist immer schön zur mehrheit so
gehören noch schöner ist es den eigenen
überzeugung zu folgen und die auch
beizubehalten über mehrere monate und
deswegen will ich daran erinnern dass
wir anfang des jahres eine sehr
spannende diskussion darüber geführt
haben was eigentlich der unterschied ist
zwischen ausgangs beschränkungen und
kontakt verboten
es macht doch für das
infektionsgeschehen keinen unterschied
ob ich nachts mit dem hund raus gehe
oder ob ich als mensch der einsam ist
gerade an den feiertagen vielleicht den
einzigen sozialen kontakt die nicht habe
auch mal draußen auf der parkbank treffe
einen sicherheitsabstand also ausgangs
beschränkungen sind der falsche weg
kontakt beschränkungen sind der richtige
weg und deswegen muss man glaube ich
sehr genau dahinter schauen was mit
einer bestimmten maßnahmen tatsächlich
gemeint ist wir haben ja eine situation
in der wir einige unterschiede haben
derzeit im dezember wenn man die
situation mit märz april und mai
vergleicht wir können aber auch sehen
dass es in bestimmten teilen der
gesellschaft einen ermüdungserscheinung
alten was man sich im märz im april im
mai teilweise auch selber auferlegt
hatte und das jetzt im privaten bereich
viele treffen wieder stattfinden das ist
glaube ich wichtig da an die menschen zu
appellieren dass hier private treffen
eingeschränkt werden müssen dass
menschen aber auch gleichzeitig wissen
was es eigentlich erlaubt was ist
eigentlich klug und was sollte man
lieber lassen und deswegen ist es
wichtig die maßnahmen nicht alle paar
tage zu ändern
auch in einem notstands modus der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz sollte
nicht ständig und permanent agiert
werden wo dann einzelne
ministerpräsidenten sowohl bei der
anreise als auch bei der abreise noch
pressearbeit machen und die maßnahmen
gleichsam wieder infrage stellen also
ein bisschen mehr souveränität ein
bisschen mehr langzeitstrategie führt
auch dazu dass menschen sich an die
maßnahmen stärker halten
wir sind keine frage da kann dem unserer
währung angewiesen dass die menschen
diese maßnahmen verstehen das ist
tatsächlich die frage ob das so ist wenn
wir auf unserer politbarometer gucken
dann haben wir gerade gesehen 79 prozent
befürworten herd oder maßnahmen das ist
auch bei einer umfrage der bundeswehr
uni münchen heraus gekommen da haben wir
dem professor aus der die gemacht hat am
dienstag gesprochen
und der hat dann etwas uns gesagt was
dann doch viele relativ stars überrascht
hat wir haben einerseits herausgefunden
dass ein großteil der menschen diesen
beschränkungen oder diesen regularien
sehr positiv gegenüber steht dann müsste
man auch denken dass er nicht wirklich
fast alle leute sich auch an diese
regeln halten möchten
nee ist nicht so also sind über 40
prozent der befragten die angeben dass
sie zumindest bereit wären diese
regularien an weihnachten zu umgehen
oder zu missachten
ja also die hälfte sagt ich mache nicht
mit die andern sollen sich daran halten
weil ich im grunde hat auch schon unter
kontrolle hat dass man nicht einfach
dann vielleicht feststellen okay wenn
das so tatsächlich aussieht wir können
das nicht kontrollieren wie sie gesagt
haben wir wollen nicht china werden wir
wollen kein autoritärer trat sein
dann müssen wir halt laufen lassen nein
wir werden das nicht laufen lassen das
wird nicht vorkommen dass es ethisch
nicht vertretbar das ist menschlich und
medizin ist nicht vertretbar
wir werden kämpfen bis wir die zielinsky
dance von 50 jahre alt sein
dann können wir die pandemie wieder
kontrollieren und wir werden also
tatsächlich diejenigen entschädigen die
auch darüber wirtschaftliche verluste
hinnehmen die werden die kinder wieder
gute schule schicken und erlauben sie
mir noch einen satz zu hören was sie
sagen widerspricht sich quasi in jedem
zweiten satz zu sagen immer im ersten
satz wir brauchen an der langzeitstudent
pandemie die unvorhersehbar ist aber
sagen sie im zweiten satz wir müssen
jeden punkt hinterfragen wir müssen
ständig alles hinterfragen wenn ich auf
eine langzeitstrategie haben will und
hinterfrage alles in jedem zweiten satz
was sie ja nachts an sich sagen wir
müssen ständig die strategie verändern
und würden wieder fragen dann wieder
spricht sich das entweder bei uns ja
eine langzeitstrategie dann muss das
auch ein shutter und sagen zum beispiel
wir haben ja eine langzeit städte wie
die regierung hat die langzeitstrategie
wir versuchen mit shut down zu erreichen
dass wir auf die cd incidence unter 50
kommen und das wollen wir dann halten
bis die impfung die immunität in der
bevölkerung gehen bekommt die
herdenimmunität durchimpfung das ist
unser land satz strategie
und ich konnte doch das mit möglichst
sanften mitteln hinzubekommen wir haben
jetzt gesehen das ist mit dem
wellenbrecher shutdown stabilisieren
aber das ist nicht nur ein paar bekommen
jetzt legen wir nach aber wird lagern
bei dem ziel unter 50 monat 1000
vorwoche in allen kreisen
ich möchte darauf antworten herr kohl ja
sehr gerne weil sich natürlich eine
langzeitstrategie und das hinterfragen
von maßnahmen überhaupt nicht
widersprechen erst recht nicht in einer
demokratie
wir müssen einfach akzeptieren dass
menschen bestimmte sorgen bestimmte nöte
bestimmte ängste im zusammenhang mit
dieser pandemie haben und dazu gehören
viele menschen die im gesundheitssystem
tätig sind die sich ein härteres
durchgreifen wünschen wenn schlusslichts
angehörigen verloren haben nicht
randalieren sorgen müssen wir
berücksichtigen wir müssen aber auch die
sorgen anderer menschen berücksichtigen
und dann macht man meinungsumfragen man
macht presse und öffentlichkeitsarbeit
und man trägt dazu bei dass es einen
öffentlichen diskurs über die
angemessenheit und die geeignetheit von
maßnahmen gibt und natürlich ist eine
langzeitstrategie in einer demokratie
nur durchsetzbar
denn bestimmte maßnahmen auch
hinterfragt werde und deswegen
widerspricht sich das überhaupt nicht im
gegenteil wir müssen genauso vorgehen
wir haben das ja in den letzten monaten
auch gesehen dass die
parlamentsbeteiligung ein großes manko
war dass die demokratischen diskussion
sogar ausgeweitet werden mussten wir uns
jetzt glücklicherweise in einigen
punkten verbessert es geht bei weitem
noch nicht weit genug und ich glaube
dass information dass das mitnehmen der
bevölkerung dass auch das eingehen auf
bestimmte kritik die wir in bestimmten
bereichen haben dass das gerade dazu
beiträgt dass wir gut durch diese
pandemie kommen werden gut das wollen
wir hier versuchen ich glaube dass ich
dann tatsächlich weil sonst werden
kommen wir hier in einer demokratie
theoretische diskussion die uns jetzt
tatsächlich hier nicht so richtig viel
weiter bringt tatsächlich ist ein großer
punkt der viele menschen umtreibt auch
bei uns hier im chat die schließung der
schulen ich habe gerade schon gesehen
auf youtube sind bei uns eher jüngere
menschen unterwegs die er macht
betroffen sind tatsächlich und die große
diskussion ist ja die schule jetzt auf
bleiben können oder zu gemacht werden
müssen weil gibt es sehr verschiedene
studien lagen zu wir haben mal die
präsidentin der deutschen gesellschaft
für kinder und jugendmedizin um eine
einschätzung gebeten das ist professor
dr -ing bock kriege lohmann und
uns folgendes gesagt die schließung von
schulen und kitas ist kein geeignetes
mittel für die eindämmung der pandemie
es ist inzwischen ziemlich klar dass
kinder keine treiber der pandemie sie in
dem gegenteil die sind sozusagen wie ein
kollege von mir immer sagt eine
sackgasse für die infektion
das heißt dass das schließen von
gemeinschaftseinrichtungen für kinder
hat eigentlich keinen effekt für die
maßnahmen bezüglich der pandemie
die franzosen haben sich jetzt extrem
bemüht in den letzten wochen und
wirklichen lockdown durchgeführt aber
ohne schließung der schulen und sie
haben sie sind ganz massiv mit ihren
infektionszahlen die mehr als dreifach
so hoch waren wie bei uns in deutschland
jetzt runter gegangen fast die hälfte
von dem was wir sehen und das haben sie
erreicht ohne dass die schulen
geschlossen wurden so also eine
eindeutige meinung dort von der
deutschen gesellschaft für kinder und
jugendmedizin auf der anderen seite sich
aber sicher bin dass diese
diskussionsrunde kirche ein ganz anderes
bild also ein ergebnis dieser diesen
zweck ich würde mir sehr wünschen
dichtgemacht werden dann kann mit der
familie schon eine isolation gehen jeder
tag zählt henry strauß schreibt fragt an
herrn coole wie lange sollen die schulen
allgemein auch offen bleiben jonas adam
möchte wissen warum der staat der
weihnachtsferien nicht schon auf beginnt
nächste woche verschoben wird diese eine
woche wird dort das bildungssystem nicht
zum einsturz bringen und ernten treue
halten meint einfach jetzt bundesweit
alles dicht machen statt
die schulpflicht auszusetzen und mit dem
rumgeeiere aufhören auf der anderen
seite gibt es aber auch eine stimme von
plötzlich auf facebook die meint ich
hoffe es gibt eine notbetreuung für die
kinder von alleinerziehenden sonst
sitzen wir auf der straße so herr
lauterbach wie sehen sie das denn also
sie sind dafür die schulen vier wochen
dicht zu machen die franzosen haben
gezeigt es geht auch anders können wir
nicht von denen lernen kinder und
jugendliche
ausweislich der durchgeführt werden die
kinder mit diesen schulen die eltern
kommt es ist doch so die epidemiologie
und so stark betroffen
dann muss man auch die schule also wo
man die in denkt wenn wir das jetzt wohl
ferien kurz- und dann kam um integration
anders dann ward unserem ist als würde
er wird unterricht in der schule nicht
gehe ich als ich musste leider unter
werden weil wir haben wieder tonprobleme
das ist ein bisschen unbefriedigend es
in dieser situation das ist schade dass
das nicht so richtig funktioniert
technisch da arbeiten wir dann auch noch
mal nach und können da vielleicht noch
etwas lernen
ich würde jetzt deswegen mal gucken dass
wir zum ende gucken kommen aber
natürlich herrn kohl noch mal die
gelegenheit geben
wenn wir jetzt sagen macht die schulen
lässt die schulen offen und lässt ihren
vorschlag moment nimmt ihren vorschlag
erst dass man quasi sagt wir müssen die
besonders gefährdeten menschen schützen
hieße das ja in der konsequenz
weihnachten dieses jahr definitiv ohne
oma und opa oder ich glaube das ist ein
ganz wichtiger punkt dass menschen ihren
kontakt zu risikogruppen an weihnachten
reduzieren ja und alle müssen sich
fragen ob ein treffen mit älteren
verwandten an weihnachten wirklich sein
muss ich will auch darauf hinweisen dass
2020 wirklich ein ganz schlechtes jahr
für die chancengerechtigkeit in
deutschland gewesen ist und deswegen ist
eine bildungs und betreuungsbereich das
worauf sich die kultusminister der
länder geeinigt haben deswegen kann es
schärfere maßnahmen im bereich der
schule nur dann geben wenn entweder eine
langzeitstrategie bei der bildung fest
steht oder wenn man es schafft eine
notbetreuung zu organisieren aber dass
einzelne menschen die eine betreuung im
privaten bereich organisieren können
oder als paar kinder haben dass die
jetzt sagen sie wünschen sich schärfere
maßnahmen das ist für menschen die beide
berufstätig sind oder das ist für
menschen die
selbstständige sind oder für menschen
die alleinerziehend sind wirklich keine
hilfe und deswegen schärfere maßnahmen
im bereich der schule oder im bereich
der bildung nur die bildungs- und
betreuungsgarantie aufrechterhalten
werden kann durch notbetreuung und durch
digitalisierung der schule als
langfristige antwort auf diese krise so
also ich sehe hier bei uns im chat
tatsächlich sehr gemischte meinungen
dazu meint hier auf youtube die schulen
können nicht so weitermachen die klassen
sind zu groß und die situation in den
öpnv aus sind katastrophal andere ich
hatte hier auch ein lehrer gerade ich
suche in normalen realschullehrer der
gesagt hat dass das ein großes problem
ist und dass er sich alleine gelassen
fühlt aber aufgrund des hohen kommentar
aufkommens finde ich den jetzt gerade
nicht ich schaue noch mal ob es hier
anders eine frage gibt es zu der
schulgeschichte
die haben wir ein wunder alle einmal
gestellt ich würde aber jetzt
abschließend noch mal eine kurze frage
an sie beide stellen weil kurz bevor wir
hier sehr leicht gegangen sind gab es
eine sonder also eine push meldung
in frankreich gibt es eine ausgangs
beschränkung an silvester das heißt die
menschen dürfen nicht draußen feiern
halten sie das für die richtige maßnahme
herr lauterbach
ich habe das richtig ok herr coole ich
glaube dass wir darauf setzen müssen
dass man kontakte im persönlichen
bereich reduziert keine partys an
silvester aber man soll bitte nach
draußen gehen weil draußen üblicherweise
die gefahr sich anzustecken auch
geringer ist als drin
also auch da bleiben wir im dissens aber
ich bedanke mich bei ihnen heute abend
dass die beide zeit gehabt haben ich
habe das mit der technik nicht ganz so
gut funktioniert hat da arbeiten wir
noch mal nachher lauterbach das hat ja
auch schon sehr viel besser funktioniert
aber das ist ja manchmal in deutschland
mit dem internet immer noch ein problem
darüber reden wer bestimmt an anderer
stelle noch mal an dieser stelle gucke
ich noch mal kurz in die kommentare also
es ging ja wirklich sehr munter herbei
euch hier schreibt jemand lauterbach
trollt mit acoustic pop das war eher
unabsichtlich tatsächlich und hier wurde
auf youtube haben sich einige
eingeschlossen und haben gemeint der
wiehre das virus sei nicht isoliert
worden
das ist tatsächlich nicht der fall und
könnte das so oft wiederholen
möchte nur weil er es nicht die studien
hätten dazu haltet es gibt sehr viele
wissenschaftler die glaubhaft versichern
dass sie das virus isoliert haben anders
kann man das ja gar nicht bekämpfen von
daher ist das hier so eine sich
wiederholende mythos der aber nichts
dazu beiträgt dass wir der
wahrheitsfindung näher kommen denn
tatsächlich ist es schon längst isoliert
worden so die hand schreibt gerade
deutsches internet lauterbach tipp
gerade internetausbau das ein schöner
kommentar
das war tatsächlich jetzt ein kleines
problem was wir hatten das in anderer
stelle haube arbeiten werden mit
sicherheit was auch den digital
unterricht natürlich erschwert aber an
dieser stelle mache ich jetzt erstmal
den sack zu sagt danke fürs zugucken
danke fürs kommentieren für die ganzen
fragen tschuldigung wenn ich allein
gekommen sind das ist halt dann doch mit
zwei gesprächspartnern manchmal ein
bisschen schwierig aber auch da arbeiten
die uns langsam nach vorne und robben
uns daran
ich hoffe er bleibt uns gewogen und
raubt mit uns zusammen mit dass zum
nächsten mal sage ich mache noch einen
schönen abend rechner
das dann macht's gut
[Musik]